Ein Sonntagsfrühstück aus Papier,
Trauben aus Glasperlen,
Fleisch aus Gemüse,
ein Gehirn aus Wolle
und ein Kopf ganz aus Lebensmitteln.
Die deutsche Illustratorin Sarah Illenberger
liebt das Spiel mit dem Ungewöhnlichen.
Alles in ihrer Umwelt ist für sie
Inspiration und Werkstoff zugleich.
So wird der Wocheneinkauf unweit ihres
Berliner Ateliers
automatisch Teil ihrer Arbeit.
Ich liebe natürlich alle Materialien,
aber Obst und Gemüse [haben]
hat‘s mir, glaube ich,
schon seit langem irgendwie angetan,
und das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
dass es so vielseitig ist, also,
und die Farben auch so kräftig sind
und dass man auch immer wieder
so ‘n Überraschungsmoment hat,
weil man nicht weiß, was man bekommt.
Es ist halt irgendwie
ein organisches Material.
Ein Atelier im Berliner Stadtteil Wedding.
Hier sprengt Sarah Illenberger den Rahmen
des klassischen Grafikdesigns:
Ihre Arbeiten illustrieren Situationen für
Anzeigen, Magazinstrecken und freie Kunst.
Flach sind sie im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes nie.
Eine 3D-Illustratorin – so könnte
man sie beschreiben.
Sarah Illenberger arbeitet
an der Schnittstelle
von Kunst, Grafik und Fotografie.
Ihr Hauptinteresse gilt dem
analogen Handwerk.
Aufgewachsen ist sie in München.
Die Mutter Schmuckdesignerin,
der Vater Szenewirt.
Meine Leidenschaft fürs Basteln
hat wahrscheinlich schon in
meiner Kindheit angefangen.
Ich gehöre zu der Generation von Kindern,
die ohne Fernsehen oder zumindest
mit wenig Fernsehen
und ohne Computer und digitaler
Welt aufgewachsen ist,
und so gab‘s genügend Zeit und Raum,
um mit dem vorhandenen Material
irgendwie zu basteln.
Und lustigerweise hatte mein Vater
ein Restaurant als ich so vier, fünf war
in München und sein…
das Lager von dem Restaurant, also das
Essenslager, war so mein Spielplatz.
Deswegen, glaube ich, hab‘ ich immer
noch so ‘n Bezug zu Lebensmitteln.
Nach einem Grafikdesignstudium in London
gründet sie mit ihrem damaligen Freund
in München ein Schmucklabel.
Schnell gerät sie hier an ihre
kreativen Grenzen.
Sie beginnt sich mit ihren dreidimensionalen
Grafiken bei Magazinen zu bewerben.
Mit großem Erfolg.
Mittlerweile zieren ihre Arbeiten
Titelblätter  in der ganzen Welt.
Ich glaube, sobald man Sachen halt
mit der Hand anfasst
und seine eigene Energie rein fließen lässt,
dass daraus auch was anderes entsteht,
was vielleicht auch menschlicher und
nicht so perfekt oder imperfekter ist.
Und ich glaub‘, das interessiert
mich einfach mehr
als die perfekte zweidimensionale
Computeroberfläche.
Sarah Illenbergers Stil funktioniert
auch auf großen Flächen.
Regelmäßig gestaltet sie in Deutschland
die Schaufenster der französischen
Luxusmarke Hermès.
Sie liebt Herausforderungen:
Ihre Arbeiten sollen von allen Seiten
gut aussehen.
Für ihre Großprojekte arbeitet sie gerne
mit Künstlern oder
Handwerkern zusammen.
In Kooperation mit einem
Berliner Schreiner
entstehen überdimensionale
Schreibtischutensilien -
ebenfalls bestimmt für einen
Auftrag von Hermès.
Meine Karriere fing eigentlich mit einem
großen Scheitern an.
Ich hab‘ in ‘ner Designagentur gearbeitet
und wurde nach drei Wochen entlassen.
Und… Meine Aufgabe war es,
so ein Re-Design
für so ein Opernmagazin zu machen,
und der Kreativdirektor sah sich
mein Ergebnis an und meinte,
es wäre leider überhaupt
kein Stück besser
als das ursprüngliche Heft und so
bin ich dann gegangen.
Und hab‘ aber von
diesem Kreativdirektor
noch was Schönes mit auf den
Weg bekommen,
und zwar meinte er, dass meine Mappe
mehr wie ein Zauberkasten aussieht
als jetzt so eine klassische Designermappe
und ich müsse mir keine Sorgen machen,
irgendwas wird schon aus mir.
Nicht „irgendwas“ ist aus
Sarah Illenberger geworden,
sondern eine der erfolgreichsten
Illustratorinnen Europas,
deren unverwechselbarer Stil
weltweit gefragt ist.